Hi guys, welcome back!
We are following on today
with our agile work series, today looking
at having an agile management style.
Do your meetings look like this?
Let’s get started everyone, todaynot a lot of things we just want to
check in with everyone, go throughany questions and make sure we’re all on track.
Or perhaps they look a little bit more like this.
Great everybody, thanks for coming, let’s get
started, as you can see we have a lot to go
through today to prepare for our project.
The role of a manager is evolving.We’re moving away from that micromanaging
where managers are expected to hold your
hand, and are constantly checking up on you,
or looking over your shoulder to make sure that
you’re doing what you’re supposed to be.
Instead of being spoon-fed, managers are now
focussing on clearly communicating goals,
facilitating teamwork and collaboration while also, encouraging a more independent
working style. Let’s stop right there
and do a quick breakdown of the language.
Today we’re looking at conjunctions.
Conjunctions are used to add two sentences,
or two parts of a sentence together.
You would know things like “and” or “but”.
Today, we are using “while”.
We used it like this:
Managers are clearly communicating goals while
also encouraging a more independent work style.
Here, while has the meaning of 'at the same
time'. It’s important to note, in the UK,
we typically use “while”, and in the US,
“whilst” is a little bit more common.
The choice is up to you, both
are OK, you can use either.
Having an agile management
style means that managers
are better able to support the different
and changing roles of their team,
helping them find the most suitable way, and
the most effective way to get the job done.
Stay tuned for the third and final video in this
series if you haven’t already, click on the button
below and subscribe to our channel, and feel free
to check out some of our other great content on
things like conflict management or interview tips.
You can see the link here. See you next time guys!